DON'T THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE NEED ABOUT A HUNDRED MEMBERS
TO GET A QUORUM SO.
THEY'RE NOT HERE YET -- BUT
WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY TO LISTEN COMMUNICATIONS
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
WE'LL START WITH -- HERTZBERG IS
OUR FIRST FIRST AUTHOR BUT HE'S
NOT HERE.
I WILL START WITH.
CENTER DOT ARE YOU READY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE OF HOW UTILITIES ASSIST
CUSTOMERS PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS -- OBVIOUSLY
RELY ON LIFE SUPPORT EQUIPMENT
WITH THE UTILITY DE ENERGIZES
POWER LINES TO PROTECT AGAINST
WILDFIRE DISHES.
LAST YEAR'S SB NINE A ONE RECORD.
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO PREPARE
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS THAT
INCLUDE PROTOCOLS FOR DE
ENERGIZING POWER LINE.
IT IS LIKELY WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF FORMAL
PROTOCOLS TO DE ENERGIZED POWER
LINES.
THE FREQUENCY OF POWER OUTAGES
WILL GROW.
THE INTERNALIZATION OF
ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT.
OF ITS OWN.
AMONG THOSE RACES THE
INTERRUPTION OF POWER NEEDED TO
OPERATE CUSTOMER BASE LIFE
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S THREE LARGEST THE
LARGEST INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
SERVE IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CRITICAL CARE
MEDICAL BASE LIKE.
WHO RELY ON LIFE SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT?
MANY OF THESE CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMERS ARE LOW INCOME IT
ALREADY RECEIVE DISCOUNTS UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE.
RATE.
ENERGY I'D CALL PRAYER PROGRAM.
I BELIEVE IT'S A MATTER OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO ASSIST LOW
INCOME CRITICAL CARE MEDICAL
BASS LINE CUSTOMERS IN THE
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY BACKUP
POWER.
THEY CAN OPERATE LIFE SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT FOR THE DURATION OF A
POWER OUTAGE.
SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES ELECTRIC UTILITY TO
DETERMINE HOW IT WANTS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND DESCRIBE IT.
IT'S SOLUTION IN THAT PART OF
THE WILD.
THAT PERTAINS TO DE ENERGIZED
DEAR IS ASIAN PROTOCOLS.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL TELLS
UTILITY HOW TO DO THIS JUST THAT
THEY NEED TO DO THIS.
I'M AWARE OF THE CLEVER CASE
SINCE CLARIFICATION SUGGESTED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND I'M HAPPY. TO
ACCEPT THEM AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WRITER -- HER GOOD WORK
[inaudible]
SO A THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THIS
BILL EVERY RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR HERE SO SO I JUST RECEIVED
SOME [inaudible]
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. TO THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
HAVE YOU SEEN.
THESE MEN WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND KATE AND THE
AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
THEY HAVE BEEN WE'VE TESSA.
YOU HAVE THE OF THE AMENDMENTS.
YOU HAVE THE AMENDMENTS AS ONE
MAKE SURE WITHOUT THOSE MATTERS.
WE HAVE A FORUM IF WE COULD --
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
HUESO.
WITH HIM A LOT.
MORE LIKE CARE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
HERE CAME [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HERE.
HILL HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE INNER STERN
[inaudible]
DOWN.
DOWN HERE WINNER.
OKAY SO ARE YOUR ACCEPTED IN THE
GIVEN THE FREQUENCY AND
DESTRUCTIVENESS OF THOSE WILD
CARDS WERE STRONG WAS PART OF
ABOUT HER.
OF EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES AND MITIGATE THEIR
IMPACT.
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR MANY OF
OUR MEMBER COUNTIES HAD THEIR
POWER SHUT OFF PURSUANT TO A P.
JEANNIE.
THE ENERGY IS A SIN A VENT THAT
EVENT WAS TO RESPOND.
TO SEVERE WIND WARNINGS IN ALL
P. GINNY SHUT OFF ABOUT FORTY
ONE CIRCUITS.
SERVING ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS SOME RESIDENTS WERE
WITHOUT POWER FOR TOTAL OF THREE
DAYS.
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF PROBLEMS.
FOR WATER WASTEWATER UTILITIES.
BUT ALSO RESIDENTS RESIDENTS
OFTEN COULDN'T FLUSH TOILETS
TAKE SHOWERS OR PERFORM OTHER
BASIC FUNCTIONS UNTIL POWER WAS
RESTORED THREE DAYS LATER.
THIS HAS SEVERE IMPACT
ESPECIALLY ON LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THOSE RELY ON
LIFESAVING MEDICAL.
SUPPORT.
ONLY BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
POPULATIONS THAT CAN'T GO OUT
AND AFFORD TO PURCHASE.
A BACK UP GENERATOR.
SO WE THINK THIS BILL MOVES THE
DISCUSSION FORWARD MOVES -- DE
INTERNALIZATION PROTOCOLS FORD
SO THEY CONSIDER THE IMPACT ON
THESE POPULATIONS WE UNDERSTAND
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO JUST
MEDICALLY SOME TO THE
POPULATIONS.
AND HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT AND
MITIGATE IMPACTS TO LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS AS WELL.
WITHOUT WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
MORNING RISK AND SALAS WITH
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS -- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL BENEFIT THE VULNERABLE
PRESS AND THOSE WHO ARE LIVING
IN POVERTY SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
YOUR TWITTER.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RHYME FOR ANY WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON.
WE ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WECERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
OF THE BILL -- THERE MAY OR MAY
NOT BE SOME CHALLENGES WITH
EMPLOYMENT.
WITH THE NEW MEMBERS WERE STORE
VIEWING AND LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THEY
AUTHORIZES AS THIS BILL WAS FORD
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EAGLE HAVE NONE AS
GOVERNMENT BEARS FIRST AND EAGLE
GAS AND ELECTRIC AND WE HAVE THE
SAME COMMITTEE APPRECIATE INTENT --
AND WOULD LIKE TO REVIEW THE
LIKE LANGUAGE WITHIN PRINT --
AND WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THE ONE COME TO MEMBERS THANK
YOU THE MORNING THIS YEAR AND
AND MEMBERS -- SENATOR JOHN I
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BOARD A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE BUT OUR LOW
INCOME AND NEED -- ELECTRICAL
SERVICES -- I REPRESENT AN AREA
WHERE WE HAVE -- A NUMBER OF
DEVELOPMENT DISABLED HOMES FOR
HAVE.
KIDS AND ADULTS OR WATER
PROJECTS THAT ARE ON RESPIRATORS
SAID.
DEPEND ON BATTERY CHARGES AND IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A BACKUP BATTERY
AND THERE'S NO ELECTRICITY.
THEY DOT -- THE NUMBER OF
MINORITY -- CONSTITUENTS ON OUR
OWN OXYGEN CONCENTRATORS THAT
NEED TO BE RUN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY.
OTHERWISE YOU DON'T.
AND AND DIE OF HYPOXIA SO -- YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU YOU YOU YOU
HAVE IN PLACE THE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT QUALITATIVE MANDATE ON THE
UTILITIES YOU JUST SAID WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE ELECTRICITY.
PEOPLE BECAUSE AS A MATTER OF
LIFE OR DEATH.
AND SO -- I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRING THIS BOARD BUT I'D LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR BE HAPPY
TO MOVE IT.
VERY WELL ANYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
YES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FIFTY ONE
SIXTY SEVENTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LESS SO.
I WAS SO I AM MORE LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CHAIN.
DODD.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
I BELIEVE THE ROLE OF MEN THAT
HAS ENOUGH VOTES LIBERAL OPEN --
SENATOR BRADFORD DID YOU WANT TO
GO NEXT.
I KNOW BUT HE WAS LATE SO --
THIS CHEMICAL COUPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO COME FORWARD.
BEN HUESO IS A FUNNY GUY WAS
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
OKAY -- THIS IS BASICALLY.
A FOLLOW UP OF YOUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HELD THE OTHER DAY
LOOKING AT THE FUTURE AND WHAT
ARE WE GONNA DO WITH RESPECT.
TO ENERGY POLICY -- WE TALKED
ABOUT IN THAT HEARING AND I KIND
OF PREVIEW THIS BILL AT THE TIME.
OF THE NOTION OF RESOURCE
ADEQUACY AND IT WAS IT HAD ONE
MEETING. TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN
WE PASSAGE DURING THE ENERGY
CRISIS TODAY IT HAS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT MEANING.
BECAUSE IT IS THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HAVE A HARD TIME
DETERMINING.
WHAT LOW THERE'S ACTUALLY GONNA
SERVE ALL THESE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANS THAT?
ARE ULTIMATELY INTEGRATED INTO A
LARGER PICTURE AND SO I THINK
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE ASKING
HERE IS THAT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
START THIS PROCESS WHERE WE LOOK
AT OPTIONS FOR SENT TO SOME
LEVEL OF CENTRAL PROCUREMENT
THIS TOGETHER WITH THE PROVIDERS
OF LAST RESORT MEASURE WHICH
WILL HERE.
IS AN EFFORT TO AT LEAST AS
WE'VE MOVED ON WITH ALL THESE
OTHER BILLS OVER THE LAST NUMBER
OF YEARS. TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE INNOVATE AND CREATE
COME UP WITH ALL THESE NEW
CONCEPTS OF DIRECT ACCESS.
GENERATIONS AND SOLAR BILL OF
RIGHTS AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE FACE.
THAT WE ULTIMATELY UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE IN THIS TOGETHER WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK.
ON WITH ALL THESE INDEPENDENT
ACTORS AND SO WITH THAT -- HAVE
ANYBODY. TO HIS TO TESTIFY.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN SUPPORT.
ONE I CAN BE ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO SPEAK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE TAKE RELIABILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY IT AS A CORE UTILITY
FUNCTION.
AND WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OSCAR ON
FIGURING OUT HOW.
TO PUT TOGETHER THE PIECES OF
THIS PUZZLE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAUREN
NAVARRO I'M HERE ALSO IN SUPPORT
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND --
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF OF SB
THREE FIFTY BECAUSE IT HAS THE
UNCERTAINTY I TO CREATE
CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET DURING
AND CERTAIN TIMES THAT CERTAINTY.
WELL WE ARE IN A TIME WITH.
THE SHIFTING ELECTRICITY MARKET
AND SIMULTANEOUSLY TRYING TO
MEET AMBITIOUS CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS WE WANT TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THIS CHANGE BUT THIS REQUIRES IS
SOMEWHAT STABLE FOUNDATION AND
THAT'S ONE THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
TODAY. FOR THIS REASON WE
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY BUT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME CHANGES TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT A STABILIZING IN A
CLEANER ENERGY FUTURE.
BUT TODAY WE NEED THE SPELL TO
CREATE STABILITY AND WE REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SAID JASON OCCURRED WITH THAT'LL
STING GILBERT ROPES AND SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION.
HOUSES HERE DOESN'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL THE DAY BUT
WE WANTED TO COMPORT EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE SENATOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR HAVING AN OPEN
DOOR AND AND TO TALK THROUGH
THIS ISSUE.
WE ACTUALLY WE OBVIOUSLY WERE
FOR PARTICIPANTS AND AND AND AND
MONITOR YOUR OVERSIGHT HEARING
LAST WEEK.
WE AGREED THAT THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE LOOKED AT
IN THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM
WE AGREE IN PARTICULAR.
BUT ON THE SUPPLY SIDE THEY'RE
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
HOUSE HE SAID HIS ALSO BEEN
ACTIVELY ENGAGE THE CPU SEE THEY
BELIEVE THERE IS ROOM.
WORK ON ISSUES FOR INSTANCE OF
POTENTIALLY A RESIDUAL BUYER FOR
LOCAL ARE A AT ANY RATE WE WE WE
WANTED TO COME COME FORWARD AND
AND AND I GET EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION WILL BE MEETING
WITH THE CENTER NEXT WEEK AND
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOT ABOUT ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION STILL REVIEWING THE
LANGUAGE AND TALKING TO THE
OFFICE OFFICE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE WITH HIM THANK
YOU.
SIR DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS BILL.
BUT BASEBALL WROTE.
DO YOU PASS YOU APPROPRIATIONS
WESO.
I WAS SO I MORE LOT.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN.
DOWN STONE AYE WIENER.
THE BILL HAS A POSTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE ROAMING THE
TARDY SENATOR [inaudible]
SIR BRADFORD.
GOOD MORNING THIS YEAR AND
MEMBERS I HAVE TO MEASURES
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING I WILL
START WITH SB TWO FIVE FIVE
WHICH IS ENERGY SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY.
AS YOU WELL KNOW AND NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX FORMER SOMEONE WILL
MAKE ONE MORE.
AUTHORED LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED CHEN ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX
THAT STATED THAT UTILITIES WOULD
HAVE TO CONTRACT AND EMPLOY A
DIVERSE POPULATION THAT -- LOOKS
LIKE CALIFORNIA THIRTY SOMETHING
YEARS AGO THAT WASN'T THE CASE
ADDS -- THEM PLOYS BOTH WHO --
WORK.
IN THIS INDUSTRY I HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN A DISTRICT.
AND SHE'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
THIRTY SOMETHING YEARS AGO --
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY SPENDING WAS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO DAY IT'S GOING TO
EXCEED TEN BILLION DOLLARS BUT
THE ROLE OF THE AND UTILITY HAS
CHANGED AND NOW WE HAVE -- YES
SPEEDS WE HAVE C. C. A.'S WE
HAVE ALSO GENERATORS.
AND ENERGY STORAGE COMPANIES.
AND DISTRIBUTE GENERATION -- AS
WELL -- AND THEY TOO SHOULD IT
TOO GEN ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX
MAKING SURE THAT WOMEN
MINORITIES AND DISABLED VETERANS
OUT LATE CHANCE AT CONTRACTING
AND UP GERMAN OPPORTUNITIES THIS
BILL.
ADDS THEM TO THAT SPACE AND I
THINK IT'S ST FOR MEASURE AND I
RESPECT [inaudible]
VERY LONG.
DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S EDWIN
LOMBARD I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE.
THE BLACK BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AS WE
THE FIVE WE BELIEVE IT'S TIME
THAT THE MEASURE LIKE THIS TAKES
PLACE.
BECAUSE WITHOUT -- WOULD WIN
WILL PUT IN PLACE OF BUSINESSES
THAT WE REPRESENT WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THIS SPACE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS REBEKAH LEE ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDSON WE
ARE VERY PROUD TO SHARE THE NEWS
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE 46%
SPENDING WITH OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ON ADVERSITY SO.
ENTERPRISES AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS PROGRAM BEING BROUGHT IN
SO THAT WE CAN CAPTURE MORE OF
THE GREAT BENEFIT THAT THIS
PROGRAM OF COURSE THANK YOU.
MINOR REPRESENTING AND SEAT
MARIN CLEAN ENERGY -- THESE ARE
A LOT OF PROGRAMS WERE DOING
VOLUNTARILY ALREADY SO WE THANK
YOU CATHERINE BRANDENBURG RIGHT
IN IN CINEMA CLEAN POWER AND WE
SPOKE WITH THE LAW.
VERY WELL ANYONE OPPOSITION.
LARA BUT ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT INTERVIEW PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION A LATE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL -- WE REPRESENT EXAM
HOLE SO GENERATORS WHICH ARE
EXEMPT THAT'S REGULATED.
FEDERAL LAW I'M WE'RE NOT UNDER
GENERAL JURISDICTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA KEY YOU SEE ARMED WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THAT CONCERN
THANK YOU.
VERY WELL COME TO THE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE ALSO HAVE A AND I ACCEPTED
TECHNICAL MOMENTS OKAY COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MISTER.
SO WILL WE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE BILL WITH AMENDMENTS --
QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL BY WAS SO
I'M A LOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CHIANG DOT.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HILL WELL I MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO I SKINNER TURNED DOWN.
STONE AYE WIENER.
THEY WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF BEEN
ON THE BILL YOU CAN TAILOR THE
NEXT THANK YOU AYE NEXUS -- SP
FOUR NINETY SEVEN AND LET ME
FIRST BY SAYING I ACCEPT -- THE
COMMITTEE TECHNICAL MOMENTS AND
I APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE THIS MEASURE.
FOR AS BEFORE NINETY SEVEN JUST
WILL ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MEAN FOR ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
ENERGY COMMISSION AS YOU WELL
KNOW EVERY YEAR WE BRING TO PAY
YOU SEE BEFORE US AND PROVIDE A
LEGISLATIVE UPDATE.
AND WE'RE ASKING THE SAME FORMER
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THEY HAVE A LARGE RESPONSIBILITY
WE JUST WANT.
THEM NOW BY IRAQ OPEN DIALOGUE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND SAME
FACTIONS TO PC.
THIS IS A STREET FOR MEASURE
EARNERS BURKE LEFT YOUR VOTE.
VERY WELL -- ANY SPEAKERS AS
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS STEVE MILLER YOU H.
ELLIE ARE I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO'S
IN SEARCH OF POWER CONTENT
LABELS I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ENHANCE -- TO WORDING AS FAR AS
ENERGY LABELING WHAT IS IT COVER.
I'VE I'VE GONE TO MY LOCAL BOARD
SMART HERE TRYING TO FIND POWER
CONTENT LABELS.
I'VE HAD TO GO TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE ENERGY COMMISSION
SAYS THAT THEY HAVE ALLOWED THEM
TO NOT PRODUCE SEIZE POWER
CONTENT LABELS.
SO I I I REALLY THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION COME
BEFORE N. B. TELL YOU ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE ACTUALLY -- CALCULATING
IN COMPLYING -- WITHOUT OR PS --
RECENTLY THEY APPEARED TO USE AN
UNDERGROUND REGULATION IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT -- THREE NINETY
NINE SEE AT THIRTY SEE.
FOR I ASK HIM ABOUT UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS I TRY TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THESE
REGULATIONS ARE IF THERE WAS A
REGULATION HOW THIS STATUTE
PROVISION WAS BEING IMPLEMENTED.
AND I'VE GOT NO RESPONSE SO I'M
HOPING THAT YOU FOLKS WHEN YOU
WHEN THEY COME BEFORE YOU CAN
FIND OUT ABOUT WHY WE DON'T HAVE
POWER CONTENT LABELS GOING BACK
TODAY.
ONE I DO I I AM WONDERING HOW
THEY CALCULATE ANY OF THEIR OUR
PS WITHOUT THIS PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE LEAVE US
YOUR INFORMATION I'LL SEE IF WE
CAN.
DIG UP ANY OTHER YEAH -- MY AGE
I GUESS THE MINUTES THAT I
SUBMITTED WRITTEN COMMENTS
THROUGH YOUR LINK ON THE SITE
I'M GOOD ENOUGH THANK YOU.
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU I NEED TO
GET BACK TO WORK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING.
ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS.
ANYONE IN US BORDER OPPOSITION.
HI I AM PRETTY PRETTY WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE ADVOCATE FOR LGBT Q.
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE STATE
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
IT'S OKAY WILL ACCEPT HER
TESTIMONY ON THE PREVIOUS BILL
[inaudible]
THE VERY WELL OF OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND WE HAVE SOME
AMENDMENTS REGARDING THOSE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE YEAH.
TAKING THOSE TECHNICAL MOMENT.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENTS HEIDSTRA PRESSURIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS GIVE PASSES
AMEND.
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MYSELF.
I WAS SO I'M A LOT.
MORE LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE TING DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
KILL.
KILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible] SEVEN
THEY SAY THAT.
I HAS. ELEVEN VOTES DO WE HAVE
ANY WILL HOLD THE ROLE IN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- STRUCTURE.
THE GAVEL IS YOURS
.
UNDER WAY SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MS ARMS RACE CHAIR.
SB TO AWAIT IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S CAN.
THAT THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THEIR TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE.
WHAT WHEN WHEN I LEARNED THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY BY?
TWENTY TWENTY THAT OF 240% OF
EVERY SINGLE ALL IN AMERICA
COMING THROUGH YOUR PHONE
SERVICE.
IS GOING TO BE A SPOOF CALLER
THEY CALL THE ROBO CALL OF SORTS.
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED.
AND AND I THINK THERE.
IS DEFINITELY A CONSIDER OUR THE
CONCERN THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
ABOUT.
THIS.
HI READING OF OUR TELEPHONE
SYSTEM.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE -- NEED TO
COMMUNICATE A HEALTH ISSUES AND
AND AND OR FOR WHATEVER REASON
AND PEOPLE ARE HAVE LESS
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR TELEPHONE
SERVICE TODAY THAN ANY OTHER
TIME.
IN OUR HISTORY.
AND THAT GOES BACK TO WHEN.
OUR SERVICE WAS VERY
[inaudible]
REMOTE.
UP PEOPLE ARE ARE FED UP WOULD
BE SPOOFING CALLS.
AND WE WILL WE NEED TO DO SOME
ABOUT IT CAN SOMETHING BE DONE
YES.
THIS BILL ARE SET THE DEADLINE
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
CALLER I. D. AUTHENTICATION
[inaudible]
AUTHENTICATION MEASURE.
SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT.
PATIENTS WOULD NEED TO BUY
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALREADY EXISTED --
AUTHENTICATES.
THE ORIGIN OF A CALL.
SO THAT WE CAN BLOCK THESE
WROBEL CALLS FROM THE SYSTEM --
THIS WOULD HANDLE THE MATURE.
NOT ALL BUT THE MAJORITY OF OF
THESE CALLS THAT.
OUR OUR CLOGGING OUR PHONE LINES
THE BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW THE CPC
TO WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO SUPPORT ACTION.
AGAINST A LEGAL ROBO CALL.
AND WE NEED IT -- IN IT IN
ADDITION TO THESE AUTHENTICATION.
MEASURES WE ALSO NEED -- TO A
VERY OF A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN.
ALL THIS LAW THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THIS LAWN THE WE IN.
EFFECTUATE THIS SMALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AS I MENTIONED REBEL CULTURE THE
NUMBER.
ONE CONSUMER COMPLAINT IN THE
NATION.
THE TO THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION.
BROAD GENERATES THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS TO THE
COMMISSION.
AND 70% OF THE SCAMS START OVER
THE TELEPHONE.
THIS IS BECOME A NINE HUNDRED
MILLION [inaudible]
DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
THE SCAMMING PEOPLE FOR THEIR
THEIR MONEY TO CALLS.
OF THE THE THE NUMBER THERE ARE
ARE OF SCAMS ARE TELEPHONES
REPRESENTS ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
MILLION I THINK ISSUE IS.
TO BECOMES THAT GENERALLY.
TEND TO BE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE ARE.
ARE VERY VULNERABLE. TO THESE
VERY SOPHISTICATED SCAMS.
AND THEY TEND TO BE PEOPLE THAT
CAN AFFORD. TO GIVE UP GIVE UP
THEIR HARD EARNED MONEY.
THEY TEND TO BE THE ELDERLY THEY
TEND TO BE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
OUR OUR YOU KNOW EASILY EASILY
RUSE BY.
BY THESE VERY SOPHISTICATED
BEATS.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME A. N. AND
SPORTINESS MEASURE -- WE HAVE TO
DO A SOME SOME.
INDIVIDUALS HERE THEIR TEST BY.
ON THIS MEASURES. TWELVE TO THE
CHAIR [inaudible]
COURSE. FOR THE VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
YES.
THE MORE YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SANDERS REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE FORMALLY
REFERRED TO AS THE OFFICE TO
REPAIR ADVOCATES -- WE SUPPORT
SB TO WAIT.
I'M SPEAKING IS INCREASINGLY --
AND PLAYED BY BAD ACTORS TO
DISGUISE YOUR IDENTITY. TO MAKE
IT MORE LIKELY THAT A CALLER
WILL CALL PERSONAL PICK UP THE
PHONE AND OFFER THEIR
POTENTIALLY [inaudible]
SELECT SCANS.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WAS BETTER HELP -- PROTECT.
FROM SCAMS DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES AND OTHER ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BUTTONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OFFERED A MEDINA HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE IN.
CATION DISTRICT.
ALI REPRESENTS AND SERVES ALL
REPAIRS IN SENATOR AND THE
AUTHORS I DISTRICT.
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO
EIGHT WHICH QUITE FRANKLY TAKES
A GREAT STEP FORWARD IN
PROTECTING REPAIRS.
IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA -- IDEA
ACTUALLY LAUNCHED A ANTI SPAM
AND SPOOFING CAMPAIGN JUST
MONTHS AGO AFTER LEARNING THAT
THIS WAS BECOMING ONE OF THE
LARGEST ISSUES.
THAT WAS REALLY IMPACTING
RATEPAYERS -- WE APPLIED TO
SENATORS -- URGE EVERYONE TO
SUPPORT THE CONSUMER COPY
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THANK YOU [inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
JAMES TRACK ON BEHALF OF CAL
TELL.
WE TO APPLAUD SENATOR HUESOS
EFFORT TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT
IS AT BEST A NUISANCE AND AT
WORSE -- PREDATORY AND A PUBLIC
SAFETY -- DANGER -- WE BELIEVE
AS CARRIERS IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
WAY SAYS OFFICE ON THE BILL AS
IT MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER JACK.
GOOD MORNING JANUARY TERRACE ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK AND THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER TERRACE ANY
OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MISTER CHAIR -- WE ARE OPERATING
UNDER THE COMMITTEE RULES FROM
LAST WEEK.
OUR LAST SESSION SKEWS ME.
USER SOMETHING WE SHOULD MODIFY
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE YOUR BILLER.
NO LEVINE NO NO YOUR AGE AND ARE
YOU ASKING IF IT'S OKAY TO ALTER
THE RULES AT THIS TIME.
THE CHARGES WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY FIND IF YOU WANNA YOU
WANNA DO A INTERRUPT MY
PRESENTATION YES.
THE PUNCH -- CAN GO AHEAD AND
THOUGH DOT ORG.
HEADED.
CENTER HERTZBERG GAS ME TO
INTERRUPT YOUR PRESENT.
IF WHERE IS HE BY THE WAY.
GO AHEAD THE THANK YOU MOTION
ANY DISCUSSION.
ANY.
ANY OPPOSITION FROM THE RULES OF
BEEN APPROVED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE INTERRUPTION ALSO
HIT -- NOW DO WE HAVE ANY.
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL.
TWO ZERO EIGHT OUR IF WE COULD
CLEAR THE SEATS FROM THE FRONT
DESK.
HEY HOW ARE YOU.
GOOD MORNING I MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAROLINE MCINTYRE I'LL BE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
OF FIRST OF ALL WE AS AN
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WITH ROBO
CALLS IN SPIFFY.
IN FACT -- IT IS THE INDUSTRY
THAT IS ENGAGED IN LEADING AN
EFFORT TO PERFECT THE COLOR --
AUTHENTICATION TECHNOLOGY THAT
WILL ENABLE US TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THESE CALLS DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE AND JUST TRY AND STOP
THEM FROM GETTING THROUGH.
AS WELL AS WORKING WITH THE FCC
AND THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- TO INSURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THE ACTUAL
PERPETRATORS OF THESE OFFENSES
ARE IDENTIFIED IN ULTIMATELY WE
WOULD HOPE PROSECUTED.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF CHALLENGES
HERE WITH THIS BILL TODAY FIRST
OF ALL IS THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
HAS NOT YET BEEN PERFECTED IN
WHILE WE LOOK AND HOPE.
TO HAVE THAT TECHNOLOGY IN PLACE
AND OPERATING AS IT SHED BY AT
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
DON'T KNOW THAT TO BE THE CASE
AT SECONDLY THIS IS A NATIONAL
ISSUE -- WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON
IMPLEMENTING THE SAME TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH BY THE WAY IS
CALLED SHAKEN AND STAR -- BUT
WE'RE LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT THE
SAME TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
AT THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND FORTY ADD THEIR
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT
THE PROBLEM THEY DO HAVE A
NATIONAL TASK FORCE.
IN WHICH CALIFORNIA IS VERY MUCH
ENGAGED AND WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO TRY AND SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
TODAY WE HAVE THIS BILL BEFORE
US THAT BRINGS IN ANOTHER
REGULATORY AGENCY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO
HAS NOT NO EXPERTISE AT ALL IN
THIS AREA AND WILL PROVIDE.
NO VALUE TO ADDING THAT AS AN
ADDITIONAL AGENCY TO THE
AUTHORITY THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ALREADY HAS SECONDLY --
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
LIABILITY ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE'VE NOT YET HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PERFECT THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE SOME.
AND WE BLOCK THAT CALL.
CARRIER MAY BEAR SOME
RESPONSIBILITY AND I OFFER YOU
THE EXAMPLE OF WHEN THERE ARE
EMERGENCIES ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES
AND THE SCHOOL MAY SEND OUT A
BLAST CALL. TO THE PARENTS TO
NOTIFY THEM OF THE EMERGENCY
THAT NUMBER MAY NOT BE COMING
FROM THAT CALL MAY NOT BE COMING
FROM A NUMBER THAT IS DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SCHOOL IF-WE BLOCK THAT CALL.
AND THAT INFORMATION DOES NOT
GET THROUGH TO THE PARENTS WE
ULTIMATELY ARE GOING TO BE
BLAMED FOR IT SO WE THAT'S FOR
TWO MINUTES TODAY ONE WOULD BE
TO ELIMINATE THE INCLUSION OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND THE SECOND WOULD BE TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING SOME SORT OF
LIABILITY COVERAGE FOR THE
CARRIERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MOVING FORWARD PRO ACTIVELY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS TECHNOLOGY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE CARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON -- CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
AFFAIRS COUNCIL FOR CTIA WERE
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY -- AS A IS
MCINTYRE INDICATED -- THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY ALONG WITH THE
CABLE INDUSTRY AND OTHER.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS IS
ACTIVELY AND AGGRESSIVELY
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
IN CONCERT WITH THE FCC AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THIS IS A CUENTA
CENTRAL FEDERAL ISSUE.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO PROTECT BUT
LET ME STIPULATE THAT NOBODY
LIKES ILLEGAL ROBOCALLS THE
INDUSTRY DOESN'T LIKE THEM
DOESN'T HELP THEM -- CUSTOMER
CERTAINLY DON'T.
DON'T LIKE THEM.
BUT IS ALSO MS MCINTYRE
INDICATED THAT THE AUTOMATED
CALLS LIKE PHARMACY REMINDERS
TRAVEL UPDATES OR SCHOOL NOTICES
DOCTORS MESSAGES.
CAN BE USEFUL.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT ALTHOUGH
THE BILL -- IS -- SUGGESTED TO
ACCELERATE THE PROCESS WE DO WE
DO NOT BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
ACCELERATE THE PROCESS THAT'S
ALREADY ON GOING.
AND AS MS MCINTYRE INDICATED BY
ADDING ANOTHER REGULATORY LEVEL --
BY A A NON EXPERT REGULATORY
AGENCY IN THE STATE -- WE MAY
VERY WELL SLOW THINGS DOWN AND
TAKE OUR EYE OFF THE BALL.
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY IS ALREADY
WORKING WITH THE FCC WIRELESS
CUSTOMERS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
CURB ON MY DIPLOMA CALLS WITH
BLOCKING FEATURES AND TOOLS THAT
CAN IDENTIFY LIKELY SPENT.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH
STANDARDS BODIES LIKE THE
ALLIANCE FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
SOLUTIONS AS TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALLER ID UP BY THE CAGE THIRTY
CASING CALLED SHAPE AND STIR AS
WE INDICATED -- THE FOR NATIONAL
WIRES CARRIES OR INTRACTABLE
MEANT SHAKEN STIR VERY QUICKLY
HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR BUT AS AS MS
MCINTYRE INDICATED -- BUT THERE
ARE OTHER -- PLAYERS INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS SO WE'RE NOT
ENTIRELY ON OUR OWN IN DOING
THIS BUT I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH.
THAT THE THAT THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY SO COMMITMENT TO THIS.
SB TO AWAIT WOULD CREATE A A
PATCHWORK OF STATE LAWS AND
pAS I INDICATED A FEDERAL ISSUE.
WE SHOULD BE PERMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
IMPORTANT TASK AT HAND
IMPLEMENTING STIR SHAKE IT
NEITHER THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION NOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS EQUIPPED TO
ENFORCE LAWS DEALING WITH ROBO
CALLS.
WILL NOT HASTEN THE PROCESS.
OF IMPLEMENTING APPROPRIATE
NECESSARY AUTHENTICATION.
IT WILL ONLY DIVERT ATTENTION
FROM THAT TASK AND ADD A LAYER
OF REGULATION THAT IS OFTEN UP
TO SEND WAS PROCESS THESE ARE
LIKE THE AND CERTAINLY IN THIS
CASE UNNECESSARY AND FOR THAT
REASON RESPECTFULLY.
WE LIST OF CLOSE TO FIFTY TWO
AWAY.
THE COMMITTEE CARLSON MISTER
MIND.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE EFFORTS. FIVE I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK COMMENTS
TO MAKE FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND THE CHAIRMAN FOR SHOWING
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE WHILE
WE DISAGREE WITH THE SOLUTION
THIS PRESENTED IN THI
PARTICULAR BILL HE'S ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT.
THIS IS A NATIONAL MENACE THESE
ILLEGAL ROBOCALLS AND TRUST ME
IF I TELL YOU THAT IF WE COULD
HAVE THIS FIXED TODAY WE WOULD
HAVE ALREADY FIX THIS PROBLEM.
WE CHAIRED THE FIRST TASK FORCE
HONORABLE CALL STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THAT'S HOW
LONG THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER. TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY LET ME EMPHASIZE IT'S
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY NOT BY THE
CARRIERS.
BUT BY OUTSIDE SOURCES.
I SPECIALLY INTERNATIONAL
SOURCES THAT ARE OFF SHORE.
SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
WITH REGARD TO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT DENNIS MCINTYRE OFFER WE
TWO WOULD ENDORSE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND ASKS FOR THE
CHAIRMAN'S CONSIDERATION -- ON
THOSE PARTICULAR AMENDMENTS AND
THEN FINALLY WE'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS STAFF
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT WE CAN EPLOY
NOW.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD -- WITH
FINDING TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS
THE TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS WILL
BE IMPLEMENTED AS SOON AS WE ARE
CAPABLE OF IMPLEMENTING IN FACT
WE EXPECT SHAKEN STIR SOME
CARRIERS WILL BE INTRODUCING
THAT TECHNOLOGY AS EARLY AS MAY
OR JUNE OF THIS YEAR -- BUT THE
OTHER SUGGESTIONS OTHERS OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC BECAUSE THERE IS
APPLICATIONS AND SOFTWARE
AVAILABLE ON BOTH WIRELESS AND
WIRELINE NETWORKS.
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON PROMOTING AND
HELPING EDUCATE CONSUMERS ABOUT
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TODAY.
AND TOOLS AVAILABLE IN THE
FUTURE SO -- WOULD LIKE TO BE AS
POSITIVELY AS WE CAN BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A CONSENSUS.
THAT THIS IS A MAJOR MAJOR
PROBLEM SO MISTER CHAIRMAN LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU AND IN SPITE OF
THAT WE DO OPPOSE THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE OF THEM ALL THANK YOU.
MISTER VINE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AM LIMITS ON
BEHALF OF CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS AND ECHO THAT
TESTIMONY OF AT THE OPPONENTS
BEFORE AS WOULD JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT NOT ALL.
COMPANIES ARE LARGE COMPANIES
THAT ARE READY TO DEPLOY THIS
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS AS ACROSS
MULTIPLE STATES.
BUT REALLY SMALL SERVICE
TERRITORIES IN EACH STATE IN A
LOT OF THEM ARE.
CLASSIC LAND LINE TELEPHONE
COMPANIES AND RURAL AREAS -- SO
THEY DON'T HAVE OF VOICE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE CUSTOMER.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT -- A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH -- THAT VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINE -- BUT MOST OF ALL
SINCE WE'RE PRETTY MUCH A SMALL
COMPANY ACROSS MULTIPLE STATES A
NATIONAL APPROACH -- WOULD BE
MUCH EASIER FOR THE A COMPANY
LIKE CONSOLIDATED TO IMPLEMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS LEWIS.
YES MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS FOR ALL
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED WE
ALSO OPPOSE [inaudible]
YOUR TOMORROW.
HOW DO ARE SILLY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON WHILE WE DO VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE BILL
FOR THE REASONS ALREADY STATED
WE MUST UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE
TODAY AND LIKE ALL TO REQUEST
CONSIDERATION OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE SET FORWARD EARLIER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DAVID KRIEGER ON BEHALF OF
SPRING ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY THER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY.
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
SENATOR BRADFORD.
I JUST LAST QUESTION AS WE ALL
KNOW.
DEALING WITH THIS COMMITTEE --
THE CHALLENGES DO YOU SEE AS AND
OVERSEEING THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN YOUR WILL HOUSE ARE
THERE THE ARE THEY THE BEST
AGENCY.
TO HELP IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM
IT DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE.
IMPLEMENTED BUT I THINK.
WE KNOW THE CHALLENGE YOU TO BE
YOU SEE IT MIGHT SLOW UP WITH TO
TRY TO DO.
AND INITIALLY WE WE'VE LOOKED AT
THAT AND WE WE NEED TO PUT SOME
KIND OF ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IN
THIS BILL NOT WE'RE STARTING
WITH BUT WERE.
WERE.
GOING TO THIS PROCESS I'M SURE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
REVISIT THAT BUT IN THE MEANTIME.
ARE THERE REALLY IS NO OTHER.
AGENCY IN THE STATE THAT COULD.
OF COURSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
CENTER DODD.
WHAT WOULD BE THE EFFECTIVE DATE
I DIDN'T GET THAT IN THIS OF
JULY FIRST?
TWENTY TWENTY AND IF YOU -- IT
WOULD WHEN WE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S AVAILABLE BECOMING OUT
THAT YEAR I GUESS IS WHAT WE
JUST HEARD WITH THE TESTIMONY
AND YOU PROBABLY HEARD THROUGH
THE TESTIMONY THAT THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE.
AND WE LOOKED AT NOT ONLY THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE ALSO THE FACT THAT THE
THEIR COUNTRIES LIKE CANADA
CANADA THAT BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH WILL HAVE THIS PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED IN THE COUNTRY.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING --
THERE THE RATED DO IT NOW --
WE'RE WE'RE BASICALLY LOOKING.
BEYOND A YEAR [inaudible]
AND I THINK THAT'S PLENTY OF
TIME.
BUT IT IT'S IT'S IT'S A BIG
PROBLEM TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE I
THINK WITHOUT A A VERY -- SOLID
POLICY ON THAT MATTER IT WILL
NOT HAPPEN ON ITS OWN.
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU WELL
FIRST OF ALL AND THANK GOD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS UP IT
IS A CONCERN -- AND I CAN JUST
SHARE JUST BASED ON THE FACT
THAT TAXES ARE DUE TO YOU KNOW
RECENTLY OF RECEIVE A COUPLE A
CALL SAYING THAT I LAID IN MY
MIKE.
COPY MY FIRST THREE DIGITS OF MY
PHONE NUMBER BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT THAT'S WITHIN MY AREA AND I
WILL PICK UP.
BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS IN TERMS
OF THE SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN I
AM YOU KNOW.
WAS A SCHOOL TEACHER IS
SEVENTEEN YEARS AND AND THERE IS
OPERABLE BECAUSE THAT WE
CONSTANTLY SEND DOWN IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW GET A COMMUNITY EVENTS
FUNDRAISERS AND IN PARTICULAR A
FEW TIMES WE HAD TO CLOSE THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND WE GOT A CALL
EARLY IN.
THE MORNING NOT TO ATTEND AND SO
I DO HAVE CONCERNS AND NOW
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO TO SIT
DOWN WITH ALL THE FOLKS WHO
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT -- THE
SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOLS NUMBER ONE
BUT ALSO NUMBER -- TWO I WOULD
ALSO ASK CONSIDER EXTENDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS I KNOW
CANADA'S DOING IT RIGHT NOW BUT
YOU KNOW WE HEARD FROM SMALLER
COMPANIES HERE THAT MAY NOT HAVE
THE CAPABILITY TO DO IT AS FAST
SO I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REALLY SIT DOWN WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN.
AND LET'S DISCUSS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT THEY EXPRESSED THANK
YOU.
YOUR ANY OTHER OF MY COLLEAGUES.
CENTER HUESO -- THE COMMENT WAS
MADE THAT.
FORTY ATTORNEY GENERAL'S AROUND
THE COUNTRY -- A FORMER CAST
PORTION ARE WORKING ON THIS
STEPHANIE.
PFIZER COMMENTS ON THAT WELL --
COURAGE BY IT.
BUT IT BUT AT THE SAME TIME AT
THE FEDERAL -- I AGREE THIS IS A
FEDERAL ISSUE.
IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE STATE
FROM DOING THIS WE'VE WE'VE
ENGAGED IN MANY THINGS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD SHOULD DO AN
HASN'T SUCCESSFULLY.
AND AS MANY PEOPLE.
HAVE REPEATEDLY SAID IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT WERE CALIFORNIA
GOES THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
FOLLOWS I THINK.
THIS BILL WOULD BE AN EXCELLENT
BILL TO TO PASS HERE LOCALLY TO
GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
THE SAME THING NATION WIDE.
WE COULD SHOW THAT LEADERSHIP
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ONLY MADE
COMMENTS TO THE INDUSTRY SAYING
YOU GUYS BETTER FIX THIS OR
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO ME.
LIKE IT'S IT'S PROVIDING ANY
REAL DIRECTION OR CERTAINTY --
IN IN IN ESTABLISHING.
A IT'S MORE OF A THREAT THAN A
REAL ATTEMPT TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND AND I DON'T THINK
THINKS EFFECTS OUT WAY.
AND THEN THERE WAS A CONCERN
ABOUT LIABILITY EXPOSURE SAY A
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE IS BLOCKED.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE STATE
GOING TO DO THAT?
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN.
WELL YOU KNOW -- AGAIN AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS THIS BILL IS IN A
BILL THAT'S INTENDED TO STOP ALL
ROBO CALLS TO TO ATTEND TENDED
TO STOP THE MAJORITY OF ON
BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
THE THE MANNER OF THE OF THE
PROBLEM IS VERY COMPLEX AND AND
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO STOP THOSE
THAT ARE GENERATED BY A COMPUTER
PROGRAM.
THAT MIMICS ANOTHER TELEPHONE
CALL AND THAT WOULD PRETTY MUCH
HANDLE LIKE 80% OR 78% OF ALL
THE CALLS ARE IN THE IN THE
SYSTEM.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT LIABILITIES
WELL?
WE UNDERSTAND THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ARE NOT THE
ORIGIN OF THESE CALLS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO TREAT THEM.
LIKE LIKE -- CRIMINALS AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS LAW DOES IT
DOESN'T -- IT IT SIMPLY SAYS
ACTIVATE VOICE.
AUTHENTICATION SYSTEM.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEN THEN
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES AND
UNDERTHIS BILL SO.
WHY WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT THEM
A PROVIDE THEM LIABILITY FROM
FROM COMPLYING WITH THE LAW I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT?
IF YOU LOOK AT HOW -- HOLES ARE
ARE ARE -- UP UP UP.
YOU MENTIONED OF CALL BLOCKING
FOR EXAMPLE -- IS IS REGULATED
BY THE FCC ALREADY THERE PLENTY
OF LAWS THAT ALREADY.
AND REGULATE THEM A IN IN THAT
AREA SO -- WHAT WOULD YOU TALK
ABOUT -- LIABILITY PROTECTION OR
A SAFE HARBOR IN THIS AREA IT
REALLY IS UNNECESSARY IT'S NOT
NECESSARY FOR THIS BILL.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING TO TO THEM
AND AND WE JUST.
DISAGREE THAT THOSE ARE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE A SAFE
HARBOR FROM A LAW.
THAT WE'RE IMPLEMENTING IT'S
JUST BASICALLY -- ON OFFRAMP TO
COMPLYING WITH THIS LAW AND AND
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO THAT
SO.
THEY HAVE NOT THEY'RE THEY'RE
PROPOSING SOME SOME AMENDMENTS
THEY HAVE NOT PROVIDED ANY
LANGUAGE.
I'M I'M OPEN TO SIT DOWN WITH
THEM AS I'VE I'M OPEN WITH EVERY --
CONSTITUENT THAT WE HAVE -- ON
EVERY BILL THAT WE RUN WE ALWAYS
SIT DOWN OUR DOORS ALWAYS OPEN
NOBODY WILL EVER SAY THAT COULD
NOT GAIN ACCESS TO IT TO ME OR
MY OFFICE ON A BILL THAT AFFECTS
THEM.
I DO NOT WANT TO PASS A BILL
THAT IMPACTS OF NEGATIVELY.
IN A WAY THAT'S UNFAIR.
BUT CAN WE IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
YES WE ARE USING MODELS OF OTHER
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AND AND OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT ARE SUCCESSFULLY -- A DOING
THIS I THINK WE CAN DO IT I
THINK IT'S WITHIN OUR POWER I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
EXTRAORDINARY UNDER OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM IN OUR LAWS ARE PREVENT
US FROM DOING THIS.
CENTER STERN DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION YEAH.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY -- BUILDING
OFF THAT THAT QUESTION THOUGH --
THE THE LIABILITY HERE IS ABOUT
THE PRO THE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THESE PLANS CORRECT LIKE IF IT
THEY DON'T PUT A POINT IT IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE EFFICACY OF THE
PLAN ITSELF IN TERMS OF THEM
THESE PLANS BEING.
GOING TO IF FIXING EVERYTHING IS
THAT THEY'VE GOT TO PUT
SOMETHING FOR THAT'S THAT'S THE
IN.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL.
THAT'S THE HOOK HERE YOU MIGHT
DO THAT IT'S VERY SIMPLE I MEAN
THE THE TECHNOLOGY EXISTS.
WE KNOW WHAT THE A TECHNOLOGY
DOES.
AS LONG AS THEY PROVIDE A
TECHNOLOGY THAT EFFECTIVELY DOES
WHAT WERE WERE ASKING THEM TO DO
THE AUTHENTICATOR CALL.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE IT'S IT'S
THAT SIMPLE EMPLOY THAT
TECHNOLOGY PUT IT INTO A FACT.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EXTENDING TIME WE TALK ABOUT
ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS THIS IS NOT
ONEROUS IT DOESN'T IT IT'S NOT A
COMPLICATED THING THAT.
WE CAN ONLY.
ARE ASKED THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO EMPLOY TECHNOLOGY
THAT EXISTS TODAY THIS IS NOT
SOME SCI FI -- YOU KNOW A
FUTURISTIC TECHNOLOGY THE STILL
HASN'T BEEN DEVELOPED.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE SIMPLICITY
OF THIS BILL WE'RE WE'RE ASKING
THEM DEPLOYED THE TECHNOLOGY
EXISTS TODAY CAN THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES BE IMPROVED IN THE
FUTURE YES AND IF IS AS OUR
IMPROVED.
I THINK THAT'S WHY WE NEED SOME
SOME LEVEL OF AN AGENCY TO SAY
YOU KNOW WORK YOU'RE NOT
EMPLOYED.
THE THE THE BEST AND THE MOST.
EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGIES OF OUR
TIMEYOU'RE STILL IN.
IN A FEW DECADES BEHIND THAT WE
NEED SOMEBODY.
TO THIS IS GONNA BE A PROBLEM
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE IN
FUTURE YEARS AS PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW VOTE.
I REMEMBER WHEN THEY CAME UP
WITH THE VIRUS VIRUS ANTI VIRUS
SOFTWARE.
WE WE THOUGHT VIRUSES WERE WERE
SOLVE WE'RE STILL.
THAT'S JUST IN OF ALL THE IN --
INDUSTRY INVOLVED IN HUMAN
PRACTICE.
THAT NEEDS AN EVOLUTION OF OF A
OF A COUNTER -- THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO BE SIMILAR HERE BUT WE
NEED TO CREATE THAT STRUCTURE
AND THE MECHANISM TO ENSURE.
THAT AT LEAST WERE FIGHTING BACK
SO EVEN THOUGH IT MAY NOT BE
PERFECT THE FIRST CUT THIS BILL
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY.
ENHANCE LIABILITY JUST BECAUSE
THAT PLANS NOT PERFECT ENOUGH
FIXING THE WHOLE PROBLEM THAT'S
WHAT I'M HEARING YOU CITY MUCH
ON AND THAT'S YOU GOT TAKE A
SHOT AT IT PUT SOMETHING FORWARD.
AND THEN LET THIS EVOLVE OVER
TIME BECAUSE I I MEAN THE THING
THAT SCARES ME IS LESS I THINK
THE TELCOS.
RIGHT IN CABLE AND EVERYBODY'S
THEY HATE THIS PROBABLY AS MUCH
AS WE DO BECAUSE IT MAKES US
HATE OUR PHONES AND HOW HE NOW
AND WE WE BLAME THEM -- BUT THE
THE THE PART THAT CONCERNS ME
THE MOST IS THE A. I..
AND THAT YOU KNOW THE ROBOTS OUT
THERE WITHOUT ANY.
I DON'T I KNOW THAT'S BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT MAYBE STAFF HAS SOME
IDEA BUT LIKE DO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ANY LIABILITY FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WERE.
EMPLOYING THIS A AYE TECHNOLOGY
TO ACTUALLY GENERATE THESE
NUMBERS AND STARTED [inaudible]
WE A MIGHT BE ON THIS GO BUT HOW
DO WE GO AFTER THE THE ROBOTS IN
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
DEPLOYING THE ROBOTS THAT ARE.
MAKING THIS POLLUTION IN THE
FIRST PLACE YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S
INTERESTING THAT RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE ARE MARKETING ROBOCOP
TECHNOLOGIES RIGHT.
YOU CAN DOWNLOAD IT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY SAYING HEY -- THIS TO
YOU YOU COULD MAKE.
MILLIONS OF CALLS THROUGH THIS
APP FOR FREE.
WERE USED TO BE A COSTLY PROGRAM
NOW IT'S FREE.
OR OR NEAR FREE.
AND THEIR MARKETING AT I MEAN
THAT'S WHY WE NEED SOME ELEMENT
OF OF BEING ABLE TO MAKE THIS A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE -- JOHN OLIVER
DID THIS AMAZING PIECE.
ON ON ON HIS SHOW ABOUT ROBO
CALLS AND HE ACTUALLY GOT ON THE
SHOW AND STARTED A ROBO CALL TO
ALL TE PEOPLE IN CONGRESS THAT
HAVE REFUSED TO ACT ON THIS.
BUT HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT.
I WANT YOU TO MAKE THIS MY
ABILITY TO MAKE THIS RUBBLE CALL
ILLEGAL BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
LEGAL AND HE DID ON TV AND THAT
KIND OF JUST.
TALKS ABOUT.
HOW HOW?
ABSURD -- THE WAY WE'RE TREATING
THIS IS INITIALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY WE'RE NOT DOING.
WHEN YOU SAY ARE WE DOING
SOMETHING WELL?
I MEAN WHEN WOULD SOMEBODY CAN
GET ON TV AND SAY I CAN DO THIS --
WILLFULLY AND AND THERE'S THERE
ARE NO CONSEQUENCES WELL THAT
JUST BASICALLY EXPLAINS THE
STATE OF AFFAIRS IN OUR COUNTRY.
THANKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR DODD PLEASE.
SENATOR I I GUESS ONE OF THE
THINGS.
I THINK I DIALED THE SAID I'M TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I'VE
JUST UNCLEAR.
IF THE TECHNOLOGY.
BY THE EFFECTIVE DATE.
OF THIS BILL -- CANNOT ASCERTAIN
THE POSITIVE FROM THE NEGATIVE.
TYPE OF ROBO CALLS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS SOMEBODY OUT THERE THAT
CAN SUIT ANY TIME ANY PLACE.
YEAH OF GIVEN THE TOURNEY EGO SU
AND SO.
MY CONCERN FROM FROM WHAT I
HEARD FROM THE TESTIMONY IS.
AND THAT THAT THAT THAT COULD BE
A PROBLEM SO I'M HOPING THAT
YOU'LL WORK WITH THE YEAH THE
OPPOSITION ON THAT ISSUE BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO CREATE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
TRY TO DO THE BEST THING THAT WE
CAN FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS.
YOU YOUR YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
EVEN WITHOUT THIS LAW ANYBODY
COULD FILE A LAWSUIT TO THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CURRENTLY FOR
FOR THE RUBLE COLLEGE ANYBODY.
THIS BILL THAT WON'T CHANGE THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT SO -- THE FACT THAT THIS
BILL PASSED DOESN'T CHANGE.
THAT'S IN OUR YOUR DISSIDENT
PANTS AT ALL.
I I GET THAT BUT IT'S IT'S SO
IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE A LAWSUIT
ON I I'M SICK AND TIRED OF THESE.
ROBO CALLS AND THE DEFENSE IS WE
DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE
FENCES.
BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
MIGHT GET THE ATTENTION OF A
JUDGE OR YES SOMEBODY WERE.
YOU KNOW WE HAD.
A YELLOW PARENTS AT THE SCHOOL.
THE THEY DIDN'T GET THE MESSAGE
AND WE WERE DAMAGE BECAUSE X. Y.
AND SEE AND SO THAT PROBABLY
RISES TO A HIGHER LEVEL ON ABOUT
EDGES.
RADAR THEN THAT WOULD BE A LOSS
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE CONCENTRATED
ON WHETHER THE TELECOMMUNICATION
HAS EFFECTUATE OR EMPLOYED OR
PUT INTO PRACTICE OF CALL AYE
AUTHENTICATION PROGRAM.
SO THAT WOULD BE.
THE THAT WHAT THE ONLY THING
THAT WOULD GIVE SOMEBODY.
REASON TO LAWSUIT UNDER THIS
BILL.
OKAY YOU SAID YOU WOULD.
BE DISCUSSING THIS WITH MY HOPE
YOU'LL ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU CENTER GOD DOES CENTER
HUESO WE TRY.
TO MAKE SURE QUESTIONS.
CREATED HAVE TIME FOR SENATOR
HERTZBERG TO ARRIVE.
SO HE'S HERE.
WE WANT TO ALLOW HIM TO ASK A
FEW QUESTIONS [inaudible]
BIPARTISAN CONSPIRACY -- I'M
TELLING YOU IT SENATOR I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
THIS DRIVES ME CRAZY.
I'LL GET TWENTY THIRTY CALLS A
DAY YOU GET THE CALLS THAT SAY
THIS IS THE IRS WE'RE GOING TO
SEND THE COPS AFTER YET.
AND EVEN IF IT'S ONE OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT RESPONSE
IT'S BAD NEWS.
RIGHT.
I WOULD HAVE A SPECIAL.
PENAL CODE FOR PEOPLE THAT
VIOLATE THIS LAW.
IT DOES REALLY BAD THINGS TO
THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY REALLY
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF FOLKS.
THE QUESTION I AM FOCUSED WITH
BECAUSE I WANT TO DO THE SAME
BILLING YOU BEAT ME TO THE PUNCH.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO IT -- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THESE CALLS ARE
GENERATED AROUND THE WORLD
THROUGH THESE AND THEY GOT THESE
RANDOM DEALS AND THEY CUT AND
TRY TO GET NUMBERS TO MIMIC
NUMBERS THAT YOU MIGHT RECOGNIZE.
AND THEN NOT REAL PHONE NUMBERS
RIGHT I DON'T THESE SYSTEMS ARE
YOU THAT YOU REFERENCE TO YOUR
KIND OF FANCY STUFF FROM FOR MY
SIMPLE WIND BUT I'D LIKE TO GET
SOME EXPLANATION ON THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE TEST RIGHT.
I HAD THIS FOR EXAMPLE WITH WITH
THE HACKING WILL BE CALL IT
WOULD PEOPLE WANT RANSOMWARE YET
EVEN THEN IT WAS LIKE YEAH WE
ENHANCE THE STUFF BUT HAD WITH
THE STUFF COMING FROM BULGARIA
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE MAKING THE
MONEY I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
OLD YOU WHEN YOU KNOW YOU'RE I
THINK EVERYBODY AGREES WITH YOUR
PHILOSOPHY AND YOUR YOUR
OBJECTIVE?
WHEN I TRY TO GRAPPLE WITH IS
HOW TO GET THERE RIGHT WE CAN
TELL THESE THESE COMPANIES TO DO
ALL THIS STUFF?
BUT THE TECHNOLOGY SO GOOD TODAY
AND THE STUFF SONY SO PHONY
BALONEY.
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY CATCH THESE
FOLKS RIGHT WE HAVE THE
JURISDICTIONAL PROBLEM BECAUSE
MOST AMER COMING OUTSIDE
JURISDICTION FINE THE STEP IN
THE CALIFORNIA YET YOU KNOW
SLICE OFF A BLADE OR SOMETHING I
DON'T KNOW I'M KIND OF TOUGH ON
THESE THINGS I'M JUST SO UPSET
ABOUT IT?
AND PEOPLE ARE REALLY UPSET
ABOUT IT YOU HEAR ABOUT ALL THE
TIME THE COMMUNITY BUT HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY FROM A TECHNOLOGICAL
STANDPOINT.
MAKE THIS EFFECTIVE USE WHAT
BOTHERS ME IS THAT WE COME OUT
WE GOT THIS FANCY TITLE WE SAY
WE'RE FIXING IT BUT IT DOESN'T
IMPACT PEOPLE'S LIVES HOW IS
SENATOR HUESO CAN IMPACT.
THE FOLKS IN MY COMMUNITY THAT
ARE PISSED OFF SO I SAY SAID
ALWAYS WAS FIXING THIS.
AGAIN -- THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WOULD BE EMPLOYED AS A VOICE OF
THE A CALLER AUTHENTICATION SO
EVEN ACTION -- IF I CAN DESCRIBE
IT IN A WAY THAT MOST PEOPLE.
COULD UNDERSTAND IS THAT -- WHEN
WHENEVER YOU GO INTO A COMPUTER?
AND THEY THEY HAVE THEY ASK YOU
TO TRANSLATE A WORD.
THAT HAS BEEN THAT IT'S KIND OF
A SQUIGGLY WORD AND IT'S NOT
SEEN IT YEAH YEAH AND THEY SAY
WHAT IS TO SAY AND THEN TO YOU
ENTER WHAT YOU READ RIGHT
NORMALLY THAT'S A WAY AROUND A
COMPUTER THAT CAN.
THAT CAN ã RESPOND OR FILL IN
THE BLANK.
BUT A COMPUTER CAN'T REALLY -- I
IDENTIFY.
CURSIVE RIGHT UP LET IS NOT EVEN
CURSIVE IT'S KIND OF IN A IN A
IN AN AUDITORY SKATED AWAY THAT
THAT YOUR I CAN PICK IT UP AT
THE COMPUTER HERE I CAN PICK IT
UP AND YOU CAN KINDA LOOK AND SO
THAT KINDA LOOKS LIKE TO BE A
KIND.
OF THE FACT HE LOOKS KINDA LOOKS
LIKE AN NINE I'M.
AND THEN YOU ENTER THAT WHAT IS
BE AND STILL [inaudible]
AND SO [inaudible]
GREAT RIDES.
IF I HAVE TO EXPLAIN THAT.
OUR SENATOR ALAN SO IT IN A
PLACE A SIMILAR TYPE OF APPROACH
TO IDENTIFYING.
A CALL WHEN IT'S COMING IN AND
AND AND IF IF IT IT'S ACTUALLY
COMING INTO Q. COMPUTER PROGRAM --
THERE'S LIKE AN ADDITIONAL STEP.
FOLLOW TO ACTUALLY ENTER INTO
THE THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM IT'S A WHOLE SET OF IT'S
A WHOLE PROGRAM.
REGULATED ACTUALLY BY THE F. THE
FCC.
A PROGRAM CALLED CHICKEN AND
STIRS IT'S NOT ACTUALLY SPELL
CHECK AND STIRS BUT IT'S AN
ACRONYM.
THAT THAT.
THAT IS A SHAKEN AND STIRRED
JUST BASICALLY EMPLOYING SHAKEN
AND STIRS MAKING IT UP.
A CODED SAY.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO OF EMPLOYEE
SHAKEN ANSWERS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA TO AUTHENTICATE CALLS.
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT NOW I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT Y. FCC HASN'T
MADE A REAL NATIONWIDE AS I
MENTIONED CAñADA BY THE END OF
THIS MONTH?
WILL BE EMPLOYING -- THAT
TECHNOLOGY TO TO CUT OUT ALL
THOSE TROUBLE CALLS FROM THERE.
TELEPHONE NETWORK I THINK WE CAN
DO THIS.
THEY CAN DO IT IN A MONTH I
THINK WE CAN DO IT IN A YEAR AND
A HALF AND AND IT'S IT'S
POSSIBLE NOW AGAIN.
THERE ARE ALL THESE DIFFERENT.
I'M WE'RE DEALING MAINLY WITH
THE THE ROBO CALLS THE COMPUTER
GENERATED TO WHAT THE POTS THAT
YOU THAT YOU ARE SO FAMILIAR
WITH IN THE BILL THAT YOU RAN
LAST YEAR YEAH.
WE'RE WITH THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
FOCUSING ON WITH THIS BILL THERE
ARE OTHER ROBO CALLERS THAT ARE
ACTUAL TELEMARKETERS THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW.
PROGRAMS THAT.
THAT CAN BE TRACED. TO AN ORIGIN
CALLER THAT.
ARE NOT ILLEGAL BUT THEY THEY'RE
THEY'RE A NUISANCE.
BUT THE ONES THAT ARE USED.
FOR CAMPAIGNS AND POLLS AND AND
TELEMARKETERS.
THOSE WILL NOT NOT THOSE WILL
NOT BE AFFECTED.
OF THESE ARE THE THE THE ONLY
ONES THAT ARE THEIR USER YOU ARE
IT THESE ARE LARGE SCALE SCAMS.
THAT SEND -- THOUSANDS OF CALLS
IN ONE DIAL.
CALL THIS NUMBER AND WHEN THEY
DO CALL THERE WAITING WITH A
VERY SOPHISTICATED SCAB.
UNTENDED TO TO RIP THEM OFF
BASICALLY.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WE'RE ASKING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS TO PLACE
TECHNOLOGY THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
AVAILABLE.
THEY HATE THE REQUIREMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT OTHER
OUTSIDE OF THAT.
AND THEN -- CHANG THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU -- I SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS TRYING.
TO GATHER MORE INFORMATION AS TO
WHAT FOLKS ARE THINKING AND FROM
A TECHNOLOGICAL STANDPOINT I DO
HAVE CONCERNS.
ESPECIALLY WITH YOU FOR THE CITY
OF THE OF THE TECH BECAUSE AS
SENATOR OF STERN AND MENTIONED A
AYE IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF A AYE
AND HOW.
HOW COMPLEX AND HOW -- EASY IT
IS FOR THEM -- TO COPY THE
SIGNATURE NOWADAYS I MEAN I'VE.
EXPERIENCED BOSS AND WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING ABOUT THE
AUTHENTICATION THAT'S ACTUALLY
CAPTURE -- BUT FROM THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OF
PERSPECTIVE I'M NOT SURE IF THE
IF THE TECHNOLOGIES EVEN THERE.
OF FOR THIS.
LEGISLATION. TO TO BE EFFECTIVE.
AND I'D LIKE TO TALK TO SOME
MORE FOLKS ABOUT THIS.
A PARTICULARLY IN THE INDUSTRY.
BUT ON THE SET ON A SEPARATE
POINT.
BECAUSE THE AG ALREADY.
HAS JURISDICTION OVER THIS I'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHY WE NEED --
THE CITY DOES NOT HAVE.
TO THE FCC DID DIDN'T THEY GIVE
AUTHORITY TO THE AG.
NOT NOT ON THIS NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
Q. CENTERING CENTER SKINNER
[inaudible]
I'M.
I UNDERSTAND OR APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT THEIR IN ANY
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS.
ONLY BEGUN TO BE UTILIZED THE
BLOCKING OF THESE -- THAT.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CALLS BLOCKS
THAT.
WERE INADVERTENT -- BUT I THINK
IF.
IF THE CONCERN THAT ENTITIES
LIKE SCHOOLS AND OTHER ENTITIES
THAT USE.
DIFFERENT FORMS OF OF AUTOMATIC
DIALING OR AUTOMATIC CALLING TO
ALERT -- TO ALERT PEOPLE OF
IMPORTANT INFORMATION
[inaudible]
HAD.
REAL CONCERNS THAT.
THE USE OF THIS OF THE TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING.
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL TO BLOCK
THE ROBO CALLS.
IF THAT WERE A CONCERN BY SAY
EMERGENCY.
ALERTS AND SUCH I THINK WE
WOULD'VE HEARD FROM SUNNOW
CLEARLY IT IS TRUE THAT NOT
EVERYONE FOLLOWS EVERY BILL THAT
WE DO.
BUT THIS IS.
THIS IS -- THERE'S ENOUGH
ENTITIES THAT USE.
THESE TYPE OF FOR LEGITIMATE
PURPOSES THAT SOMEONE WOULD HAVE
HEARD ABOUT IT AND IF THIS WERE
REAL.
REALLY SERIOUS CONCERN THAT WAS
REALLY GOING TO INTERFERE WE
WOULD HEAR FROM THEM WE ARENOT
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LIKE THAT BEFORE US RIGHT NOW.
THE OPPOSITION THAT WE HAVE IS
THE TELECOMMUTE TELECOMS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THEY WOULD
ALWAYS PREFERRED TO HAVE.
NATIONAL RULES THAT THEY ABIDE
BY EVERYWHERE AND NOT -- YOU
KNOW ARTS OUR STATE BY STATE
APPROACH BUT SOMETIMES WE HAVE
YOU AND DAD.
ANYWAY JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
POINT THANK.
ANYONE ELSE MY ALL RIGHT IN
CENTER HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST SIMPLY OF THIS IS A
THIS IS A GROWING PROBLEM I I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS WILL BE
SOLVED WITHOUT.
ANY KIND OF A REGULAR IN
INTERVENTION I THINK THIS IS --
UNFORTUNATELY THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN FIX THIS.
AND FOR ME THE MOST COMPELLING
ARGUMENT AND ALL OF THIS WHETHER
YOU LOOK AT YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW
THE THE COULD.
WHETHER IT'S EMPLOYABLE OR NOT
THE THE MOST COMPELLING ARGUMENT
IS THAT IT.
IT IS BEING DONE IT CAN BE DONE.
CANADA IS GOING TO SHOW US THAT.
IT WILL BE DONE.
AT AND I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN USE AS A IF IF.
YOU KNOW AS A MODEL.
OF OF WHY A WHY WE CAN DO IT AND
HOW WE CAN DO IT SO -- I'VE
REALLY ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
THIS EFFORT. TO CLEAN UP.
OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM
WHICH IS NOW IN IN IN NOT JUST A
A VERY VERY EXTREMELY BAD STATE
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY DRIVER MOTION.
I HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
THE ROLE.
SB CHOATE TO PASS TO DO DISH.
SO.
WHAT'S SO I MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHIANG DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
INNER SKINNER AYE STERN
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NO WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible] SIX ONE
AND THE NUMBER.
HE'S CHARMING SO HE'LL COME IN
AND WILL ALSO.
THIS.
IS A MEDICAL [inaudible]
SACRAMENTO -- YOU RECALL THE THE
ROLE ON THIS BILL.
AS ON THE BILL THAT I JUST
BROUGHT THEM.
SB TWO OH EIGHT TO PASS TO DISH
[inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
CHANGE.
HILL.
MCGUIRE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THE WORLD NUMBER FOUR
YEAH.
YEAH I AM WILL START WILL START
FROM THE BEGINNING.
WHERE SUMMER?
FOR WELL THAT LET ME START LIVES
SURFING BEGINNING -- WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THIS BE.
ONE SIX SEVEN DODD.
WE HAVE A TO PASTOR PROPS.
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE PAST IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO CHIANG MCGUIRE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- WILL GO TO
NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER.
TWO NO THAT WE JUST DID THAT --
ONE NUMBER THREE IS BRADFORD --
SP.
TWO FIVE FIVE THE CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS DO YOU.
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT BUT SIX
ZERO MORE LACK.
CHIANG.
HERTZBERG.
OKAY HERTZBERG AYE MOORLACH AYE.
CHIANG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
WIENER.
I MEAN I ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR OKAY SB -- THREE FIFTY
HERTZBERG.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
HE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CONTENT.
EIGHT ZERO MOORLACH. THREE SEVEN
FOUR THREE OFF I'M SORRY.
I WITHOUT EVERY VOTE FOR NO THAT
WAS ON HERTZBERG.
OKAY I WHICH WILL BE LIKE
WILDLIFE.
I WANTED TO STAY NEUTRAL ON THAT.
ONE NO WE DO. THREE VOTING ON
HERTZBERG.
SET UP OKAY MORE LAX.
DO YOU PASS THE MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS MOORLACH I CHANG.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
HILLS.
SENATE CHIANG IS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS -- A CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM -- FOR SB THREE
FIFTY HERTZ FIRST.
STEVE HAS HIS DEFENSE TO PERHAPS
CHANGE -- THREE FIFTY FIVE
CHIANG AYE STERN.
OKAY I'M.
GOING TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE BRAD BIRD SB.
FOUR NINE SEVEN ARE THERE ANY UP
SOME NUMBERS ON THAT ONE YES
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE
THEM SB FOUR NINE SEVENTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG.
BY CHIANG AYE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
WHERE I?
I WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
ONE SIX SEVEN BY DODD. TO THE
MEMBERS DO PASSED THE MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG.
HI CHIANG AYE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
WHERE I?
THIS IS.
GOOD OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER -- TWO THAT BILL --
PASSES.
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SB TO AWAIT HUESO.
WELL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ONE MORE LOT.
CHIANG [inaudible]
HILL.
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE STERN
MARK STERN HI.
THIS BILL COMING [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEN I WILL JUST -- CLOSER ROLE
ON THAT.
YEAH SHE'S NOT.
WE'LL CALL THE CLOSER ROLE.
OKAY [inaudible]
GO.
DO YOU WANNA.
ON NOT STERN ON ON ITEM FOR
HERTZBERG [inaudible] THREE TWO
THREE FIVE ZERO DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN
[inaudible]
STERN AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT IS THERE ONE
THERE WERE MISSING ON SB TWO
FIVE FIVE BRADFORD A STERN YEAH.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG STERN.
STERN AYE [inaudible]
LIZARD.
COMMITTEE OKAY I WILL CLOSE ARE
WE ARE WE DONE.
THERE WITH THAT.
AND YEAH SINCE.
YEAH WILL CLOSE THE ROADS OKAY.
THERE ARE FIVE FIVE YOU'RE OUT
THERE.
IN.
WE'RE NOW ADJOURNED